you don't have to become a king or a
president or a CEO to improve not
everyone has to be a fitness model to be
in better shape if you're someone who's
400 pounds you can get down to 250
you're still a big dude but think how
much healthy you are your clothes
Mobility walking up the stairs quality
of life in every way is that such an
unreasonable goal but for a cynic it's
like what's the point you're still fat
well yeah you are but come on these are
extremely different qualities of life so
I think it is a very non-rational
emotional perspective that tries to
present itself as if it's realistic and
cool-headed it's like oh you're naive
you're a Pollyanna I'm not being hopeful
in the sense of nothing bad happens I'm
not being hopeful in the sense of the
bad guys aren't really that bad but
there is a lot of pressure of you know
kind of just head down go to the factory
do the work don't hope for anything
better and it's just like